there's a big difference in the
strategies and mindset you need to make
a hundred thousand dollars versus a
million versus 10 million or 100 million
today we're going to talk about how to
go from that 10 billion dollar Mark 200
million
[Music]
in this video I'm assuming you are
already at around 10 million dollar Mark
wanting to get to 100 million dollars
which means you already have thought or
improved in the following areas or else
you would have never gone to the 10
million what I'm going to talk about
afterwards is what it takes to go from
the 10 million Mark to 100 million
dollars so what have you already gotten
good at to get to the number that you
are today here's 11 skills of which many
of them you've probably already mastered
number one persuasion number two reading
people three sharing the wealth which
means you already kind of have a good
comp structure with sales with bonus
with profit sharing to make sure your
best performers stay motivated or else
you wouldn't keep those guys number four
leverage number five recruiting number
six Energy Management number seven how
to process issues latest time management
nine is how to manage money 10 is how to
be aggressively patient so those things
I'm not going to talk about in this
video here's the other 10 things that we
talked about how to make your first
million one saying yes to almost
everything two figuring out the formulas
and doubling down on them three
increasing activity four removing
multiple streams of income mentality
five protect your centers of influence
six leverage building the sales team or
the right funnels or contact seven pick
one religion and stick to it eight
protect your credit score nine track
your savings and expenses ten
specialized early generalized later now
let's talk about how to go from 10 to
100 million it's very different so Point
number one very confusing you're gonna
get to a point that you have a lot of
time on your hands you're gonna be like
wait a minute why do I have so much time
on my hands well that's because you
hired people you got the right C Suites
if you're doing 10 million you
officially have been given back maybe 20
30 hours a week I'm doing a call last
week with a few 7c Suite Executives and
won the Coss Pat my company is doing 35
million a year money's coming in we're
breaking records every month but I have
nothing to do and I don't even know what
to do at this point is this one I
celebrate is this one I go golf is this
one I relax what do I do now you're
there for the first time trust me you're
going to be confused because people
around you and your family they're gonna
say how's it feel knowing you made it
how does it feel known you're already
there the same meaning I'm talking about
a guy is sitting next to the 35 million
dollar guy says in 2021 I made 10
million but in 2022 I made 500 000 my
entire business collapsed why do you
think that is so how were you working in
2021 is that was working 60 hours a week
said how are you working in 2020 it says
now 2022 was relaxing enjoying Going to
the Country Club my handicap improved
that's exactly what happened too often
when a person gets to 10 million and
have all the time in their hands rather
than working on the business now
strategies hiring recruiting growth
marketing next campaign next technology
next whatever maybe they get distracted
thinking they're rich boom they're 10
million very quickly becomes 4 million 3
million two million so Point number two
is manage and boredom this kind of goes
for number one but let me explain to
what this means you know they say in
bodybuilding most of the time if anybody
ends up retiring bodybuilding you're a
champion you go through divorce and
sports NBA MLB NFL hey the champion the
MVP right after the end of the career
they typically get a divorce why your
spouse is used to you being gone eight
months nine months intense intense
intense you're competing now you come
home now your spouse could be your
competitor typically they say divorces
happen after vacation because you're not
accustomed to spending time with your
wife and kids for a week you come back
you choose the enemy all that stuff so
look none of this stuff is anything new
when you're bored I mean Benjamin
Franklin one time said Idle Hands or the
Devils play things when you have too
much time on your hands you got drugs
you got alcohol you got partying you got
gambling and you got money and now you
got time and you're working get on your
business oh my God no one's going to
notice what you're picking up on the
side except for your personal life so
just the second point you got to make
sure you fight if you're gonna go from
10 to 100 like you still haven't given
me a strategy first we gotta make sure
you don't screw this thing up that
you've built up to 10 million to get to
100 million dollars so look this is a
natural transition into our sponsor
today which is better help and what
better help is the largest online
therapy platform in the world they have
25 000 licensed therapists to talk to
the reason why we decided to team up
with these guys as a Founder as an
entrepreneur as an operator we hate the
fact that we need to talk to somebody
and sometimes you're alone but you need
to talk to somebody but you don't want
to go into an office with seven other
licensed therapists and you're waiting
and when your client sees you and says
oh my god oh what are you doing here I
go to this is your therapist as well
you're embarrassed to do that right
because God forbid if somebody catches
you doing that this eliminates that
because you have 25 000 licensed
therapists to choose from if one doesn't
work they'll replace it for you at no
cost so look if you're hard charging
entrepreneur you're running you're
making all the decisions you have a
little bit of stress anxiety you feel
lonely like oh my God I don't know what
you do I feel overwhelmed join the two
million other people like yourself who
have taken charge of their mental health
with an experienced better hop
therapists getting betterhelp.com
forward slash valuetainment once again
betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment Point number three is
again a contradiction on how to make
your first million when I said how to
make your first million say yes to
almost everything in this area to go
from 10 to 100 million you have to say
no to almost everything let me explain
to you why yesterday at 11 o'clock at
night I get a text with some guy talking
about there's a fire we got to put out I
got to get you on a call I said uh
what's it about he tells me XYZ they
said have you talked to this person yet
no how about that person how about this
person up to them come to me last this
is not a 10. he goes to them he says we
scored it all we're good to go whereas
seven years ago I would have said yes
now you have enough firefighters to put
out fire to address issues that you no
longer need because the company needs
you to be working on the big that's what
the company needs if you're only working
on protecting what you build and you're
not playing offense the company is going
to get smaller and smaller everybody in
the company is hoping you're doing
strategies to take the company to the
next level and to do that you need to
say no to the small things and let your
leadership team handle that and if it's
anything that turns big they gotta come
to you you need to focus your time into
the big things Point number four is
about focus on what areas you need to go
deeper on let me explain to what I mean
by this so if you're doing 10 million a
year and you're already at a number like
that you have better data you probably
have a tracking record of different
quarters different months different
seasons different days different weeks
just today we got data that showed us
number one day in America to sell your
home is May 23rd think about that number
how do we have that data well because
somebody tracks the data of what is the
best selling date to sell your home
summer town it's kind of like saying
when you buy a motorcycle when it's
winter when do you not buy a motorcycle
in July when you buy convertible
typically December January because no
one wants a convertible if the weather
is cold when you not buy convertible do
you see how this thing goes so you now
have data to look at and say okay here's
what I'm noticing this customer we can
really focus on these three customers
and go deeper with them this director
he's been doing a lot she's been doing a
lot I think this person's got what it
takes to be a c-suite let's go deeper
let's invest into her here let's invest
in what school do we need to send them
to what next course do they need to
learn do they need to go to an executive
program at Wharton Harvard whatever and
maybe they need to get better this is
the time to go find out exactly what you
have and say we're going to go deeper in
these following areas within the
business okay so Point number five and
six are going to contradict each other
so just kind of hang tight number five
is HR there's a big difference between
running the team with less than 50
employees you got 13 employees 14
employees 22 employees maybe even 38
employees it's still manageable you all
of a sudden go to 100 employees 200
employees 500 employees now you're
National you got offices all over the
place now you have HR issues now you
need to do training on HR now you have
all these different challenges you're
facing with HR so this person doesn't
get along with that person this person
doesn't like working with this person
there was a follow now that person had a
breakup these two employees dated
there's a lot of different things you're
dealing here which means your HR team
has to be a better quality HR team with
more experience understanding different
Dynamics creating better structures
better guidelines clearer guidelines
benefits all of that needs to be shot
because if you want to recruit better
Talent that's what they're going to be
asking you what's your health benefits
what's your retirement plan what's this
what's that these are the types of
questions that higher quality be people
going to ask when they come to your
company so HR is going to give you some
problems don't make HR an area you don't
pay any attention to so Point number six
here's the contradiction with Point
number five the company's growing in a
different management style you have to
do to manage 200 employees versus 25.
here's what's going to happen as you
start hiring people with degrees ivy
league Harvard I went to Wharton I went
to Yale I went to this I went to this
they come in and all of a sudden they
say well I propose we do a three-day
work week the other two days they work
from home but your culture doesn't fit
that it doesn't work with your industry
it doesn't work with your culture but
you're sitting there in your mind you're
like yeah but this guy went to Harvard
maybe he knows what he's doing and I
don't know what I'm doing you second
guess yourself and then you compromise
your culture when you compromise your
culture now they know you don't stand
for anything so now they know there
really has never been a culture in this
company it was all about winging it just
because somebody comes with a fancy
degree with HR it's important that yes
standards may change yes you may have
systems yes you may have certain things
but not at the cost of the culture that
got the company to 10 million dollars
that didn't happen actually mentally you
did a few things right to get the
company to 10 million don't compromise
it just because somebody comes with a
fancy degree Point number seven your
business is slowly becoming a small
country maybe a village maybe a city
depending on the size meaning there's
different political parties here's what
the political parties look like you've
got the Republican Party the Republican
party or the people that have been with
you from day one very protective of the
company they take a lot of Pride they're
protective of you and anybody that comes
in they're afraid they're gonna hurt the
company right you have to stay generally
the Independent to the right a little
bit then you have the Democratic party
which is people that are coming from
Fortune 1000 companies Fortune 100
company Fortune 500 companies with fancy
degrees Harvard Yale Wharton well you
know so here's what we need to do if
we're really going to make this work we
have to start doing this and these guys
are like no we're not doing that listen
my hand's been clean I don't even touch
paper anymore here's what I do that's
not the culture we have we have startup
mentality you're out of your mind in
this moment when I went through it first
time I screwed it up let me tell you
what I did the second time second time
around I brought a consultant in and I
said look I need your help she came in
here's what we're going through as a
company I need you to go interview you
everybody tell me what questions you're
going to be asking go interview them and
let's do meeting with me being in there
don't tell me who gave what answers but
let's go through it no problem she went
in okay and she stayed with us still
today by the way this lady's been doing
business with us for nearly seven years
she went in She interviewed everybody
with different questions and it came
back here's what people are worried
about here's what people fear here's
what people this and I'm sitting there
like okay I'm listening to okay that's
on me that's on me I can't see who would
do that I can see how we need to improve
that then all of a sudden everybody felt
safer to speak openly once it was safer
and you played the role of the middle
then you can help them come together
because debate becomes safe it's hard to
do you have to do it if you don't do it
you will have different Clicks in your
organization and then when lunch comes
you'll see seven people all from the
same Department go to lunch six people
all from the same philosophy go to lunch
we don't have a company you have a bunch
of Divisions in your company so you got
to do this early before it's too late
here's the next part this one's tricky
you have to pay very close if you bother
if you've been through this before you
know exactly what I'm talking about
you're going to have former disgruntled
employees you just are how do people be
become disgruntled employees very simple
you fired them they left you they had
Equity they came in and they quit three
years before the company sold they came
in and they decided to leave because
they didn't think the company was going
to be big and the company blew up and
missed out they're not happy about it
you think they are there was a book
written I want to say in 1985 or
something like that called The
Accidental millionaire do you know what
the whole book is about the whole book
talks trash about Steve Jobs and Steve
Wozniak do you know how many 60-minute
shows has been done where former
employees talk trash about how horrible
Avid boss Steve Jobs was do you know how
many many you know why because people
love that drama they love it and you're
going to have it so how do you handle it
some of them you can't do nothing about
nothing others you have to learn the art
of letting people go gently and the
bigger you get they're going to be even
more Angry the more money you make
they're constantly going to be angry
because can you imagine the question
they have to be asked for the rest of
their lives here's what the questions
sound like hey wouldn't you like
employee number 28 at Facebook Hey
wouldn't you like at Google at the
beginning you think they like those
questions it should never happen because
if they would have stuck around they
would have been Millionaires and they
left so it's not easy so you have to
figure out a way to work with former
disgruntled employees and try to let go
of them as gently as possible and don't
piss them off even more than you already
have even though you didn't do anything
you just grew a company this kind of
goes to a number eight and you'll see
where I'm going with this it's hard to
do but you have to do it let me explain
to you what this is there Comes A Time
like for me I was a person all my
friends would pick on the basketball
team because I was tall and big but I
wasn't that good of a basketball player
so some of the guys that were smaller
than me I was always on a starting five
lineup when we're playing pickup then
all of a sudden I noticed they're not
picking me no more the other guys got
better than and one of our friends who
was very good in basketball he stopped
picking me and that feeling as a 14 year
old was like how come you didn't pick me
was I not good enough I wasn't I just
wasn't the other guys got better than me
in basketball in baseball I was still
there were picking me up at the top
because that was a good hitter and I
would run I was fast I could cash them
all but in basketball I was no longer
top five trust me I hated it as a kid
what does this mean in a company at a
certain point you're gonna have to
upgrade the talent that you currently
have you have one of two choices I
either the people that I've been with
you are going to tell you why you need
to pay them 50 more but they're the same
as they were two years ago you either
have to challenge them to say who they
need to become and if they don't you
have to go hire somebody from a company
a startup experience that you don't
currently have and bring them in and
shake it up a little bit those people
don't up their games well guess what
they're not ready for the next phase of
the company if they do after games now
you got two killers going to the next
phase of the company but you cannot sit
there trying to please everybody knowing
these guys have been kicking back
working a regular schedule because you
allow them you are compromising getting
better quality Talent at a company and
the company deserves you to have the
courage to make the tough decision and
upgrade your talent all right Point
number 10 this one's gonna be crazy so
now you're rich you got money you know
it you're doing good you got a lot of
things you can lose the house cars the
fame the freedom the VIP table in the
back of the restaurant you go to and
your waitress Maria treats you royally
and you love it but now you could
potentially lose it so what do you do
you do what many teams who have a big
lead in the first half of the Super Bowl
or an NBA championship they come out
second half into coach plays scared like
the Atlanta Falcons did against Tom
Brady they're up 28-3 look oh my God
just let's play safe let's not make any
big risks so you don't throw the ball
anymore to score touchdowns boom and a
guy like Tom Brady comes takes you out
you're out of business it doesn't matter
how big you are even the biggest
companies have to take risks you got to
take risks you ain't that big you're
only at 10 million so if you hesitate to
take the next level risk at this phase
you're gonna pay a price I've taken a
lot of risks maybe on paper didn't make
sense but I had to do it at that season
at the company or else we would have
stayed where we were at you also have to
do the same I'm not telling you be
Reckless not at all there's levels to
risk I have the time to be a little bit
more methodical you have the time to be
a little bit more strategic but can you
compromise taking risks you cannot if
you want to get 200 million but I got
two bonuses for you two bonus points one
of them is valuation today is all about
being Tech enabled I had a guy that came
in here the other day where Sinai he's
doing 32 million a year good size
business extremely profitable and we sat
there for a couple hours and we're
speaking and he says hey you know I've
been stuck at 32 million for the last
two years and I can't move the number
like this what do I do I said so tell me
about your team your org chart your
management team your savings your
schedule what are you doing
expansion opportunities ads marketing so
we went through all of that right and I
said tell me about your technology uh
what do you mean what technology do you
have well I don't know what you're
asking what is your technology how much
it is automated well I'm using this and
I'm using this okay what can you add
because your goal you want to sell this
company for a billion dollars yes today
no one's buying any companies that's not
backed up by great technology Netflix is
all about their technology Amazon is
technology Facebook is technology Google
is technology even small companies that
are being bought for high valuation it's
being bought because they have unique
technology so what are you doing to
increase the valuation of the company
because of Technology we invested in our
Tech a software called bamboo and we put
10 million dollars into it well that
increased the value of the company not
by 10 million dollars it increased the
value of the company by five times the
investment we put into it like this
within 18 months because it was Tech
enabled I was able to update my leaders
bulletin for competition from once a day
30 000 times a day so if a guy submitted
an insurance policy in New York and it
hit the leaders within three seconds
everybody in the country knew that
person New York just wrote a policy I
didn't have that before communication
nearly 10 million messages on this
bamboo from Agents across the country
talking with each other we didn't have
that before that created competition
that was able to get things quicker
sharing clay I got this client can
somebody go talk to them no problem
messages messages took the company to
the next level so if you want to get to
100 to the next marker you have to think
about how you can make your company Tech
enabled and the extra point that I have
the second extra point that I have is
your network if you grew from 100K your
friends are making 100K you're also
making 100K great but if you want to get
2 million your net work business Network
Associates some of them have to be
making a millionaire they're going to
talk to you and you're going to see how
they act and think to make a million now
you get to a million now if you had a
million everybody runs you only had a
million you want to get to 10 when you
got to get a couple colics that are
making 10 million you got to upgrade
your network and be around others that
are doing 100 million a year even though
you're at 10 million to be like oh my
God I'm the smallest guy in the room
here the more you're the smallest guy in
the room the more you grow the more
you're the biggest guy in the room the
less you grow very simple if you always
want to feel like you're the most
powerful guy in the room keep doing that
if you want to keep growing always be
the smallest Scandal somehow some of you
keep growing and then all of a sudden
the competition gets smaller and smaller
and smaller but stronger and stronger
and stronger so you may want to increase
your business networking go hang around
with some people or find them and
certain masterminds that can challenge
your mindset that was the extra credit
Point number two that we gave so if you
watch it till the end and you're not a
10 million we're like I'm curious
because I think one day I will be no
prom so you got two videos to watch that
you haven't seen yet one of them is how
to make your first movie if you haven't
seen a watch this the other one is 11
skills to master as a millionaire if
you've now watch that click here to
watch it either way if you got value
from it subscribe to the channel take
care everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]